the coronavirus has emptied out cities
fewer people are driving cars or
boarding planes factories are idled as a
result the world is burning less oil but
many of the world's major oil producers
have been pumping more than ever
leading to a crash in oil prices low
prices normally put cash in the pockets
of drivers and fuel burning businesses
like Airlines but this is different
consumers like low prices but in today's
environment where so many people are
quarantined people cannot benefit from
low oil prices so there's no winner in
this current situation emili´s say that
the current bust is so bad it can
radically reshape the oil market here's
how we got here
oil producers most pressing problem is
that a lot of people don't need it to
products by April the consumption of
petroleum in the US had fallen to the
lowest levels in at least 30 years
demand for gasoline has declined by
nearly half since mid-march jet fuel
consumption plunged by more than 70
percent since then the trend is similar
around the globe
it started in China where the first of
billions of people around the world
began to shelter in place to slow the
spread of the deadly virus for 2020 oil
demand oil consumption will decline it
increased every year but the decline
because of what's happening in China
what is happening in the global economic
this is one reason by late March
billions of people around the world are
staying home analysts estimate that
global demand for crude oil will decline
by about a third or about 30 million
barrels a day during the pandemic
meanwhile oil is piling up with nowhere
to go
pipelines are filling refineries and
storage tanks like these are brimming in
some oil is being stashed at sea on
ships that's because the global pandemic
arrived right as production around the
world was surging in recent years the
saudi-led organization of the Petroleum
Exporting Countries and other nations
like Russia have coordinated production
cuts intended to prop up oil prices they
were working together to boy prices as
US producers flooded the market
but the truce was short-lived in early
March Russia and Saudi Arabia couldn't
come to terms on a new round of cuts in
Saudi Arabia turned on its taps market
turmoil is about more than just the
virus oil prices suffer historic
collapse late Sunday after Saudi Arabia
shocked the market by launching a price
war against one-time ally Russia
meanwhile US producers continued to pump
even as prices fell US production hit a
record of 13 point 1 million barrels a
day in late February and stayed around
there through March US companies were
reluctant to slow down having borrowed
heavily in recent years to drill wells
build pipelines and maintain fleets of
expensive machinery with billions of
dollars of debt coming due they couldn't
afford to stop pumping but by late March
already low oil prices had fallen by
more than 1/2 and the pain became
unbearable you can see it in this chart
which shows the number of drilling rigs
in Canada and the United States the
drilling recount declined as companies
cut their budgets in mid-march by April
US production began declining in April
the Saudi Arabia and Russia where the
government's are supported by oil sales
rekindled their market alliance they
convened a group of 2300 producing
nations who agreed to once again
restrict output and support prices they
agreed to reduce their collective output
by about 10 million barrels a day so far
the market has not been impressed
Goldman Sachs analysts called it a
historic yet insufficient cut oil prices
fell on trading opened the next day
what's a really fascinating question for
the energy industry for the oil industry
is will this dialogue between Saudi
Arabia Russia the United States and
others will endure beyond immediate
crisis we could be entering a new era of
international dialogue on the oil market
of the likes we've never seen before